in the countryside south of paris a new
biogas plant almost blends into the
horizon it was set up by six local
farmers including luke zhanota to
convert their farm waste into energy
each day they dump crops vegetables and
other organic matter into the system
every day we put 30 tonnes of waste into
this container it goes up into the
grinder water is added and then it's all
pumped into the fermenter where the gas
is produced
the plant is an extra source of revenue
for the farmers whose work says luke is
at the mercy of an increasingly
unpredictable climate but it's also now
playing a role in helping europe to
reduce its reliance on russian gas
the government five years ago set a goal
that france would produce 100 of its gas
by 2035. we're not there yet of course
but what we're doing helps us become
more autonomous in terms of our energy
needs
the gas is purified into biomethane that
is cleaner than natural gas it's then
fed into a pipeline to the nearby town
of
the gas produced at the farm helps to
heat hundreds of homes in this town as
well as the swimming pool and the
hospital
in france three new bio gas plants are
switched on each week as private and
public investment in the sector has
increased in recent years
we need to develop these types of energy
as part of the work we're doing in this
region to transition to more sustainable
sources like biogas
as the eu tries to wean itself off
russian gas in response to the war in
ukraine biogas alone can't fulfill the
bloc's immediate energy needs but it's
clearly part of the picture and a step
towards a more sustainable future
natasha butler al jazeera humboldt
france